nos échanges le confirme et vous le
savez cette la conviction que la france
porte depuis le début il n'existe pas
d'autre solution qu'une solution
européenne pour surmonter cette crise
[Musique]
certains nous disent à juste titre qu'on
aurait dû aller plus vite plus fort mais
cette europe des vaccins de la recherche
de la coordination
elle est bonne moi je la défends
[Musique]
tu vas me dire qu'on n'aura pas besoin
de se motiver par exemple la tsarine
alors on a absorbé la merkel
envisageaient oui donc comme on n'aura
pas besoin de se motiver tout nick v
état était un vaccin en complément
[Musique]
cet homme aime particulièrement cocasse
que l'union européenne qui depuis des
années nous vend le principe de libre
concurrence
le principe de libre entreprise sur le
territoire de l'union européenne
iliad aujourd'hui stoppée le scout 5 au
simple motif qu'en fait elle raisonne
par dogmatisme
on est encore dans l'idéologie l'union
européenne qui déteste la russie sans
aucune raison alors que aujourd'hui le
seul objectif c'est d'assurer la santé
des français
et moi je regrette très fortement que
monsieur breton ne fasse pas passer la
sécurité des français avant son
dogmatisme complètement adhérents
[Musique]